the Joe Rogan experience well good
didn't Google by Boston Dynamics as well
they bought a robot company I know that
which is like what are you guys planning
trouble everybody's email you have the
number one search engine on the planet
Earth you have the number one browser
like what are you guys doing what are
you doing over there yeah you made
robots are you all but don't you want to
be in the room yeah you don't want to be
in the room but you know some of their
choices are a little bit questionable
it's there's so much there's there's
science but then there's so much there's
social decisions you know that they're
making in turn right like what people
get to see and talk about in here and a
lot of is based on the zeitgeist it's
based on you know the current state of
politically correct ideology what you
can and can't say or can and can't do
and that becomes really dangerous
because you're kind of controlling
information you're throttling
information like you know Tulsi Gabbard
is suing Google for what is it like 50
million dollars or something crazy like
that they say that they purposely
stifled her search engine results so
that people wouldn't be able to find her
as easily and they've she's apparently
proven it well so it's not a pure
information based company there's
ideology behind it there's motivations
behind it that you know politically
leaning motivations right yeah so no
yeah when he goes into that world on
yeah like oh I forget about that
sometimes when you're like I want to be
in the beta break their rooms you know
well there was an internal memo that
were they referring to ben shapiro and
someone else I think it was Jordan
Peterson and maybe Dennis Prager as
Nazis which is hilarious because both
Ben Shapiro and Dennis Prager are both
Jewish so it's like their their
perception of who person is this was
brought up this is brought up by people
in in Congress like they had to have
hearings on it trying to figure out like
what is Google doing like what are you
allowed to
how are you allowed to define people
internally in your memory memos and then
of course once you call someone in Nazi
then you can act as
if they're announcing and you know
stifle any sort of search on them or
stifle results or you know yeah
point point people in the direction that
you think would be better for Humanity
versus just pure information and it gets
it's very weird you know but as a
technology company look they're
amazingly just what they're doing with
Android and Google searching and Google
assistant and Google Maps is by far the
most the superior map application on the
planet Earth and it's constantly getting
better and constantly gathering up new
information I mean part of me loves the
fact that they exist and part of me is
like that is too much power has too much
power for one right one company to be
able to influence people one way or the
other so what's uh what's your
silhouettes that Joe Rogan's solution is
something like that regulations no well
I'm too stupid for this this I need to
rely on people that have actually spent
real time studying the effects and
understand it from a very deep level I
don't I understand it that it's I
understand that it's problematic I just
don't understand what the solution is
and I don't know if it's even it's just
a free distribution of information
across the board because then what do
you do about actual Nazis like if you
find the act like yeah there's a new
Hitler and he arises and really does
want to exterminate the Jews what
happens there you just allow that guy to
be on Google easy and Google Hangouts
with Nazi hangout they're planning on
exterminations and we're the right
where's the next outwits you know no I
don't think that that shouldn't be the
case so what is the case do you allow
white supremacists on there to organize
rallies [ __ ] where where does freedom of
speech end you know yeah it's very
complicated questions yes
we're all learning to navigate